[Music]
whenever you have a place where humans
have just walked away there's always a
bit of an eerie feel to it like
something bad happened to produce this
sudden
vacuum a Boneyard of rusting ships sits
nearby there are vessels tied up to
docks which look like they're half
sunk It's a Kind of a creep
picture
here analyst turn to local
records they reveal the ghost island is
the legacy of a series of brutal bloody
events that began more than a century
ago what these reports tell us is that
this area was the setting for some of
the most harrowing non-combat operations
of the first world
war in October 19
4 turkey's Ottoman Empire enters World
War I siding with the German
Empire while Germany focuses on
capturing Western Europe ottoman forces
attempt to secure countries around the
Caspian Sea including
aeran turkey joins the war on the side
of Germany because she sees this
fantastic opportunity to seize all this
new
territory but there's a problem
that means going up against its historic
rival
[Music]
Russia the better equipped Russians
devastate the ottoman Army slaughtering
23,000 and capturing a further 7,000 as
prisoners of
War Russia who is Fielding a massive
Army is fighting against a rather weak
ottoman Army on the other side and the
result is thousands of of Ottoman
prisoners that all have to be dealt with
somehow somewhere to buy themselves some
time they send all these seress
prisoners to this desolate Rock on the
Caspian Sea and that is known as the
aisle of
Nagin surrounded by miles of sea the
island becomes a kind of World War I
Alcatraz for thousands of wounded and
disease ridden
prisoners
imprisoned in the filthy barracks in the
image countless starve to
death the island is alive with snakes
the men are forced to eat the snakes
because they're not receiving
nourishment from their Russian
captors if you were sent to nargan you
could only pray that you would make it
out alive or that you would die as
quickly as
possible
in September
1918 Turkish forces Liberate the
Island's surviving
inmates the following decade it and the
rest of aeran are captured by the Soviet
Union and the horrors witnessed here
enter a new
chapter the island eventually evolved
into one of the Soviet Union's prisons
it's where Stalin would send perceived
enemies of the state or political
prisoners between 1936 and
1938 Stalin launches a ruthless campaign
to solidify his power known as the great
Terror over 1 million people are
imprisoned and
750,000 more murdered by the
state of all the gachs to be sent to
during the Great Terror nagan Island was
probably the worst it essentially was a
place to be sent to if it were going to
be
executed Stalin uses nargan Island to
execute both high-ranking officials and
thousands of ordinary
citizens as his paranoia increases so do
the horrors inflicted on the prisoners
there at the height of the great Terror
the state actually surpassed the idea of
just executing political
prisoners to transitioning to whole
scale extermination of these
people there's about half a dozen of
these unusual shapes with a central area
that is much larger they're edged or
built into the
ground and there's no clear reason as to
why they're
here
the giant symbols appear to be made from
Stone given that they're cross-shaped
perhaps there's some link to
Christianity however they would only be
something you could really see from the
air Christians in China have long been
persecuted for their
faith so if they are related to
religious worship then that would make
sense to have them hidden from normal
sight
Chinese Emperors first banned
Christianity in 845 CE decreeing that it
is a dangerous foreign
ideology during the 19th century it
makes a return When thousands of
missionaries travel to the
country China was seen as a possible
fertile new ground for Christian
conversion the number of Anglican
missionaries from Britain went up
100-fold around the same time economic
disputes lead to conflict between London
and
Beijing the so-called Opium Wars end in
a British Victory and result in waves of
persecution against westerners in
China there was a group of rebels that
became known as The Boxers that led a
violent Uprising against this Western
intrusion they would roam the
countryside inflicting their vigilante
justice wherever they could on Chinese
Christians and any Christian
missionaries that they happen to come
across the boxers believe themselves to
be
bulletproof between 1899 and 1901 they
slaughter over 30,000 Christians and
force countless others into hiding
is it possible that this is some way
that Christians were able to display
their faith in a manner that wouldn't be
immediately obvious to the
oppressors when investigators excavate
the structures they discover that they
are indeed connected to a period of
extreme
Bloodshed but one from an earlier time
in China's
past
archaeological investigations have shown
that they're far far older and have
nothing to do with
Christianity in fact what they are are
the Royal tombs of the Shang
Dynasty the Shang Dynasty Rises to power
in 1600
bcee they are pioneers in the fields of
math and astronomy and invent the first
form of Chinese writing
in many ways the Shang are the founders
of Chinese Cultural
identity but there was a a dark side to
them as
well much of the shang's history is
recorded in the blood they spilled
during their long military
campaigns the Shang kept a very large
standing army and were very successful
on the field of
battle their military might was
unparalleled they developed things such
as horsedrawn chariots then they
developed the compound
bow at the time these were absolutely
revolutionary
Technologies the Shang go on to rule of
480,000 square mile Empire a territory
larger than
Texas they construct the Monumental
tombs in the image to honor the kings
that have brought them Glory
these structures tell us how powerful
the Shang were and how they wanted to
manifest their power by these massive
tombs excavations of the tombs revealed
that the Shang did not restrict their
Bloodshed to the
battlefield Within These tombs we find
sacrifice body is literally stacked up
in the corridors leading to the main
burial
Chambers the Shang believe that
supernatural beings govern natural
phenomena like drought and
storms to appease these Spirits their
kings slay up to 300 people at a time
and Inter them in the
tombs not only were people sacrificed
but the manner in which they were
sacrificed was absolutely horrific I me
you got things like beheading
dismembering and even being buried
alive as the shang's power grows so does
the amount of ritual Slaughter witnessed
at the Royal
tombs over a 200-year period some 13,000
people meet their end
here an orbiting camera scans Okun asima
island off the coast of hu
Japan at first there doesn't seem to be
anything particularly extraordinary
about this
island it looks like a lot of the
islands you'd see in the Pacific
Ocean however local records reveal
there's something very strange about
this 180 acre land
mass there was a period of time when
this island didn't
exist and any nautical map any sort of
land mass map of the area simply did not
include this particular
Island the island is absent from all
official Japanese documents for several
years before reappearing in the late
40s the island is not there and then
it's back again why would the Japanese
make an island
disappear The Disappearing Island's
location offers a
clue what's interesting is that the
island is close to
Hiroshima after the bombing of the city
the Japanese government needed secure
locations to treat survivors perhaps
that's what we're looking at
[Music]
here the detonation of the 15 kiloton
little boy bomb 1900 ft above Hiroshima
kills or injures around
135,000
people as Medics begin treating the
wounded many begin to succumb to mystery
illnesses the Japanese government
suddenly had thousands and thousands of
horrifically injured people to treat and
the effects of radiation were not really
understood at all they wanted to keep an
eye on them to kind of further examine
the potential effects of nuclear
radiation and
exposure authorities quickly rushed the
injured to secure location for
monitoring could this be an island where
survivors were
relocated could it be that the island
was then kept secret to protect those
people Declassified intelligence files
confirm the island is indeed linked to
this country's military
past but its Vanishing Act is the result
of a different equally devastating type
of
weapon the reason the Government tried
to deny even the existence of this
island was that it represented one of
the darkest chapters in Japanese
history in the early 20th century the
Japanese begin researching chemical and
biological
warfare reasoning that producing
bacteria is cheaper than making
Conventional
Weapons in 1929 authorities established
a secret facility on the island in the
image the main role of the factory was
to manufacture poison gas and
specifically mustard gas the problem was
that the Japanese had previously signed
the Geneva protocols which banned the
use of chemical and biological weapons
so it's no surprise they didn't want to
publicize the existence of this
Factory in 1937 Japan seeking to expand
its territorial influence in the region
invades
China
during the conflict it deploys chemical
weapons manufactured on the island
killing or injuring 880,000
[Music]
people the Japanese Imperial Army used
chemical and biological agents in the
most inhumane and depraved way against
Chinese
people during World War II fearing
allied forces are stockpiling chemical
weapons of Their Own
[Music]
the Japanese government turns the
factory over to a secretive unit called
731 a first Unit 731 was experimenting
on how to help Japanese soldiers
withstand chemical
warfare but after a while it veered off
into a completely different territory
something that really didn't even
resemble scientific research at
all unit 7 31's first experiments take
place on animals such as
rabbits but it soon moves on to human
test
subjects they would for example take
Chinese prisoners of War tie them to a
post in the middle of a test range and
then they would expose these victims to
chemical
agents another disgustingly common
practice was to expose prisoners to
lethal doses of x-rays this is
completely
horrific
some historians estimate that around
600,000 people die at the hands of Unit
731 they were a peasant people and the
Japanese felt that they were Unworthy of
life and they were nothing more than lab
animals during World War II the island
Factory uses Unit 731 so-called research
to produce 6,000 tons of poison gas and
other chemical agents
the justification for these experiments
was to advance military technology it
really was atrocities that nowadays
would be equate to being crimes against
humanity following its surrender in
September
1945 the Japanese government attempts to
cover up Unit 731 brutalities before
abandoning the
island they escaped from the island with
the full knowledge that when the
Americans get here there's going to be
hell to pay we're going to have to face
the
music however in a twist of fate many of
the murderous scientists Escape
punishment for their
crimes disgracefully you actually have
the US government playing an active role
in this cover up and giving immunity to
some Unit 731 researchers in return for
access to their
data seven death decades later an
unlikely Legacy of The Unit 731
experiments remains on the
island around 1,000 rabbits have taken
up residents here rumored to be Escape
EAS from its reign of terror all those
years
ago it's hard to imagine a more stark
contrast than the horrific Grim past of
this island and its
present
a drone passing over a remote forested
area has captured something unnatural in
the landscape
below this is really
perplexing because it's a kind of donut
or Bagel shaped structure right in the
middle of this Grove of
trees you've got what looks to be the
giant horseshoe rising out of the
ground it has to be man-made because you
can see stones that have been carefully
aligned sticking out of it like
ribs the newly discovered structure
measures around 300 ft in diameter and
appears to be many centuries
old what this was for is unclear but if
it's ancient it's a really extraordinary
Discovery I've never seen anything quite
like it and I'm really excited to
discover what it actually
is the mystery structure's location
intrigues
historians it sits in a region which
held great strategic value to countless
civilizations including the Greeks
Hittites and
Persians turkey has been a land bridge
between Europe and Asia for hundreds of
thousands of years
because turkey has been a Crossroads for
Humanity determining who built this and
what it is is a real
[Music]
challenge Alexandra suspects the
structure's shape could offer a
clue I wonder if this is a burial
M turkey's known for its incredible
tombs which don't look dissimilar to the
structures in this
image
there is evidence of human habitation in
Turkey stretching back more than a
million
years the Warriors and rulers who fought
and died here have left their Mark in
the form of giant ornate tombs and
mums turkey has ringed tombs that
include the great tomb of King Antiochus
I first at the very top of Mount neit
so it's possible that this could be the
Lost Tomb of an ancient ruler of this
[Music]
region the image coordinates guide
Alexandra to an isolated Valley North of
the town of
nili when she reaches the site its true
scale becomes
apparent oh
wow it's
huge I knew from the aerial images that
it covered a wide area but this feels
Monumental you would have been able to
see it from all over this area which of
course is exactly what you'd want if you
were a rich and powerful
ruler as Alexandra explores the ruined
structure she discovers more evidence
evidence that it once served a
ceremonial
purpose what you don't realize from
above is just how deep this depression
in the middle
is it really does make me think there
might be a ritual element to
this the circle is perhaps humankind's
oldest
symbol for some ancient peoples it
signifies eternity or the earth and the
[Music]
heavens
for others it represents a gateway to
the spirit Realms and the
[Music]
afterlife many cultures in prehistory
have used circular
structures as ceremonial
locations so the fact that this is a
circle could suggest ritual
use so many ancient sides are built
around as a central area where the
rituals took place just think of stone
Heng and other Neolithic
sides exploring further Alexandra finds
elements of the structure not visible in
the aerial
images oh look at
this oh that's
[Music]
amazing a series of arches up to 20 ft
High ly in the perimeter of the giant
Circle this is just not what I expected
to find here at all it was clearly built
by people with considerable technical
skill The Arches are evidence that the
mystery structure is the legacy of an
Empire that ruled these lands some 2,000
years
ago these arches are a classic giveaway
they date from the Roman
era because the Romans developed Arch
architecture and turn it into as much a
science as an art form
the arch is a key component in Roman
architectural Mastery because an arch
enables you to to to build up enormous
structures which are very
[Music]
strong the structure did indeed have a
ritual
purpose one that satisfied the blood
lust of tens of thousands of
people it has these connected archways
and this huge circular
shape I think this is a lost Roman
Amphitheater this is almost
unbelievable